what
is i
that very sticky
attribute
[Music]
i'm pumped
to share
some of the recent
explorations
of the nature of reality
grateful to amanda riso for
that track called anata
i am a strange loop we'll be talking
about that
very anata or no self
as well as i am a strange loop douglas
hofstetter
one of the most profound
realizations that happen in
enlightenment
is recognizing that
awareness
which we do gym repetitions
in order to become truly
aware of awareness and abide
as awareness rather than the thought
clouds that appear and disappear
we stay as the sky
of awareness in which the thought clouds
arise and pass
that in itself is a very profound
revelation that that very diamond
was around the neck the whole time
rather than seeking externally for peace
and happiness in maya
in the dream delusion rather we
recognize
that awareness is nature itself
is peace and happiness now
after that profound revelation we
undergo another profound revelation
which is that
well we share our same source
we share our awareness awareness is not
personal awareness is impersonal
awareness is shared impersonal eternal
okay this is why we've been told
that that which you seek is the seer
the seer is god
okay so now we have this very all
inclusive awareness impersonal
shared all eight billion of these units
okay so now we begin calling this the
one
i we begin calling this the one god
self the same single self only
this very formless non-physical
existence awareness is
formless the very nature of the subject
is formless it's non-physical
and then we also recognize that that
very nature of the formlessness is to
witness
still the the infinite creation
just like is happening on all of the
modulations
on our devices right now
as you watch this is that you're getting
these audio
and video modulations that are happening
that are changing moment by moment the
very
impermanent nature versus the very
permanent nature
and so now you get to this point
where
a very profound place in enlightenment
is
the very abiding as
the all-inclusive awareness or this
capital s self-realization or god
realization or the one i or the one god
self or all inclusive awareness or the
great i
am being formly still and endlessly
witnessing
infinite creation
now this
is going to get a little bit
strange looby
so
this is why the seeking impulse is
the truest thing about you
because even god is an attribute
even the all-inclusive awareness the
very great i
am the very one god-self
the one i
is an attribute
and so then we ask who what observes the
one
i how do we
access that which
observes the one eye
and what is that
and am i that
rather than the all-inclusive awareness
the great i am
might i be that which observes the great
i am might i be the source
of the great i am
so this is the very sticky
attribute that we mentioned the very
last
attribute as you go in
or as you go out it's the very first
attribute
the one i is as the first last attribute
our
crown assumption
the title of the video the crown
assumption
is this capital s self the most
poignant intoxicative
simulation by
the agentless
so
the meaning of the question what is
i goes
beyond
the all-inclusive awareness
to what is known as
the anata the
no self the very agent
less
you turn the great i am
into an object and transcend it
and you gain access to your source the
very no
self
that creates
the first attribute that is the most
poignant
intoxicative simulation crown
assumption of self
this is also very powerfully
visualized by
many of the greatest artists of all time
m.c escher is one of them
and the very
simple visual that
helps the process become
easier to understand is is that you
are the source that makes perception
possible you are the very
creator of perception
so you create god you
simulate god you
are the no self void
shunya that out of emptiness
manifests the first attribute which
is god
the capacity to
observe to witness
so your very sticky
eye that is so
intoxicative and it's so
sticky
it's so salient it's such an
illusion it's such a simulation
but it's a complete
not what you think it is
and yet it is our most powerful
tool awareness
witnessing observation god
is the most important tool we need
to be able to have the power to
know
the very that i am
enables us
to know to experience
to observe to witness to be
aware
so
the crown assumption is self
the very first attribute is an
assumption
well that changes the whole game of what
enlightenment is
for many people including myself
to have a very unified
theory of what is actually going on
in awakening and spirituality and
enlightenment is very
important and mission critical
it's one of the things that excites me a
lot
about bentino massaro and the team
in the no limit society
the very persistent
excitement of the highest caliber
around being
the navy seals of spirituality is
gorgeous and so you have things
like this that can be shared
with people that enable them to more
easily
have a navigable roadmap for awakening
ah
can join me
if you'd like to relax a bit
and when we do that what we do is we
relax
away from the mind toiling us around
between
thought clouds and we abide more and
more as the formless subtle
awareness and then
we can relax even more into not
describing our experience and then
become more and more comfortable with
that
one god self and holding
that entire all-inclusive awareness
turning that into
an object and transcending even that
recognizing oneself as source
recognizing oneself as the one infinite
creator
and recognizing the fact that the very
sticky first
attribute that's illusory is this crown
assumption of
self avoid
void is the meeting place of self no
self
so the very infinitude and nothingness
and the
is where that very no
self-self stickiness first attributeness
illusion takes place
nothingness and the crown assumption of
self are best
friends inextricable again
that very warm of
void avoid
is the meeting place is the very best
friendship that is inextricable
will perpetually be a sense of i
you'll never be able to get rid of the
sense of i there has to be an
observation there has to be a witnessing
there has to be an awareness
you have to have that in order to
experience
or know or have an i
am-ness in realities
everything is a creative forcing
function
of that very avoid void oh
never still
yet perpetually still
and this is when it is talked about
transcending
the very nature of coming and going
transcending the very nature of birth
and death
transcending the very nature of
unmanifested and manifested
avoiding infinity
of ego and enlightenment
of self no self
all these
polar juxtapositions that assist
us develop lexicon and lattice work
around the maps that help in the process
to move away from suffering
towards awakening yet at the same time
those very poles are
transcended into
ineffable perfection that we already are
enlightenment is knowing this then
peacefully doing the laundry being
awake as a normie
we'll get to this in a bit but the
stopping of the seeking impulse
at awareness let alone
impersonal awareness
let alone getting stuck even prior to
that at things like
trauma work
or parroting
oneness and love without becoming aware
of awareness
this is why a
unified theory is so needed
because the very nature
of reaching milestones in this process
of piercing the veilless veil walking
through the gateless gate
in one's awakening slash enlightenment
you don't know when
what you hit as these milestones is the
quote
end end the quote done
done
and it's cute because sometimes the
conditioning
of the costume will step forward
and reveal itself because it will become
attached
it's happened to me
but so if you get so far in the process
of awakening to this quote and and
done done where you transcend even the
most
illusory intoxicative attribute of
self itself
and really truly recognize oneself as
source as the creator as the very void
shunya emptiness of that no
self that is eternal
that is ineffable that is perfect
that is undergoing the process of these
dreamed creations
infinitely if you can get
where that no self
and self meet for that little
illusionary dance
that first attributive intoxication
you be you can become more of a jedi
in navigating all of these layers
because as frank yang has mentioned on
the show several times there's
really this process of even as you get
the quote and end that the dissolving
of that sense of i even at the level of
the one god
self that the dissolving of that
the very transcending god itself
seeing god as your tool as what you
simulate
to observe to witness to aware to know
the very nature of your costume
has an attachment that's been
conditioned
for a long [ __ ] time
and to be free of the [ __ ] crown
assumption
is itself a very long
arduous
process that is also sudden as it is
gradual
yet it is also something that like frank
said can take a long
time like a dozen years
and
it's very trippy because you've spent
your entire life with a sense of
i and now the sense of i is dissolving
piece
by piece until it goes
and this isn't to say that you lose
individuation you don't lose
individuation
you just gain knowledge of the true
nature of reality
and then like is written here you
peacefully do the laundry
and you be a normie but you're
at a level of being able to navigate the
entire
stack of this so-called unified theory
and when you know that this so-called
crown assumption this first
attribute of awareness of self is
even an intoxicative illusion itself
you really become more empty and as you
become more
empty you don't attach
identity to your
expression your fireworking
in order for your costume to firework in
this
emptiness infinite vortex that we're in
where the universe is [ __ ] itself
that your firework if it doesn't know
its true nature across all of these
layers of enlightenment and awakening
you will have blind spots and when you
have blind spots
your conditioning will come up and when
your conditioning comes up you will
commit
malevolence or you will be egotistical
you will have a service to self
dynamic that has a lack belief or a need
or seeking validation
and it's super duper subtle the more
empty you can be
the more you can also allow the
spontaneous rigpa to emerge
that very groundless ground to emerge
spontaneously in pure alignment
with the one intelligence
versus being aligned with some sort of
egoic onion layer of conditioning
that you're not even aware of
and so empty empty empty it out
be free of your conditioning be free of
your psychology be free of your
attachments
be free of your layers of identity
and become a really good steward
shepherd
for the global enlightenment
for maximizing our potential
and so this is why
with our homies
that we respect tremendously
like douglas hofstadter
i am strange loop
is a great way to put this because
in the end we are self-perceiving
self-inventing
locked in mirages that are little
miracles of self-reference
so the very nature of the crown
assumption of
self is that it is self
inventing we invent
ourselves emptiness invents the self
some of these zingers are really
and so
take your time with
the digestion of said
understanding that even the very sticky
intoxicative i
that you've been referencing your entire
life
is completely self-invented
and yet we intelligently
as intelligent infinity we
intelligently use these
self referencing self-inventing
sense of i which is why god
is this first attribute seeing or
observing or witnessing or awareness
is so [ __ ] profound
we're smart because we know that that's
the core
thing and you have to have this
best friend's relationship between
nothingness
and the first attribute of awareness
so that you can't tell the difference
because if you can tell the difference
imagine how
unable you would be to experience
reality
basically no self and illusory self
have to be married as [ __ ] have to be
best friends
in order for there to be able to be
awareness or an observer or a witness
the power to know the feeling of
i am
we as intelligent infinity are
genius
we as source
leverage the coolest
feature which is such
an indistinguishably inextricably tight
relationship between
nothingness and everything that the
sense of
[ __ ] i is simulated from that process
and that's why this a mirror
mirroring a mirror
resonates because when you
empty the mirror of the conditioning
what you get is you don't get
the conditioning that comes up
you don't get the entity
with all of its conditioning
rather you get entity
empty pure
mirror and when you're a pure mirror you
are a pure mirror mirroring
a mirror that again
depending on the conditioning it might
have
those impurities
and by impurities we mean distortions
which mean
attachment to identity of
conditioning lack beliefs needs seeking
validation
and this is why bentino and teams navy
seals of spirituality
is on fire because this no limits
society is all about
purification
it's super profound
so there's a bunch of mirrors mirroring
to mirrors that's what this is the sense
of
i inside of that mirror dne
it does not exist it's illusory
it's sticky and it's intoxicative
so even the simulated self
is the last cheeky [ __ ]
pre-emptiness void as frank yang would
say
that very illusory sticky intoxicative
sense of
i is the last cheeky [ __ ]
the simulated sense of self dissolve
dissolve dissolve dissolve dissolve so
emptiness void
so it's like a series of clicks which
we're gonna go through but
you click away from
the cloud of thought
in mind towards the formless subtle
awareness
and then you click from the formless
subtle awareness
into the very impersonal all-inclusive
great i am of god
and then that begins to really feel like
i'm witnessing
infinite creation and then
you recognize more and more subtly
infinity and you recognize more and more
subtly that even
god itself the very all-inclusive
awareness
can be popped
as an object transcended
and this very voidy shunya
formless voidness
emptiness is
no selfie
and things like this really assist in
the process
when you do dive into the very
kaleidoscopic the very fractally
the very
practice of abiding more and more as no
self
you really can't find the sense of i
it's totally simulated it's like trying
to
find the sense of i when you create a
dream
you go to bed you dream a reality
at night and you simulate the observer
in that reality
for you to witness it where is the sense
of i
completely fabricated completely
simulated there is no
self that entire dream
is its emptiness appearing as
form and that form being made of
emptiness
as is said in the heart sutra
and so these mystic tradition wisdoms
have been taught for thousands of years
and so today we're in modernity and
we're confused in the parable of the
prodigal son trying to find peace and
happiness externally
and getting hit with all the
sledgehammers of suffering and we're
turning inward we're becoming aware of
awareness
there's a lot of perverse [ __ ] that
keeps people from even
popping out into being aware of
awareness in the first place
and there's more that's why this entire
unified theory is so
so critical and yes it is literally
the last cheeky [ __ ] that simulate
itself
that's why the whole idea of buddha's
anata
is so
in many ways
spiritually and mystically
aimed to be understood across the
traditions because
theravada buddhism specifically having
this very anata
no self as such a high
last stage of enlightenment is
in a sense not necessarily found across
the other
mystic traditions
whereas one could say things like the
very nature of atman or the very nature
of
soul or the very nature of self
that that's very in a sense applicable
for
the creations themselves
that's why there feels like there's this
very sticky continuous
cyclic process of your involvement in
the ascension
within this creation within this very
specific planet
orbiting the star with the civilization
that's been evolving and ascending and
dialectically interplaying as
lila the divine play that there feels
like there's that sense of self the
sense of soul
the very atman
and so there are ways to also again
very unifyingly create an understanding
that spans all of the layers and lenses
rather than get
stuck and so last stage of enlightenment
the automatic but illusory sense of eye
disappears dissolve as frank yang's been
saying on the program dissolve more and
more dissolve
dissolve dissolve the very
cheeky [ __ ] simulated self
it's the crown assumption
because it's so sticky it's so
intoxicative it's so
inseparable inextricable it's
the very first most important
aspect for us to be able to design and
immerse ourselves in these dreamed
realities
so even god the all-inclusive awareness
the one god
self is simulated the very
cheeky cuntness of even god the
all-inclusive awareness
itself the very great i am itself
all right so i think i'm going to
share with you guys this as well
and that'll be a wrap along with a
couple
last images
so basically each spiritual concept as
frank yang is also mentioned on the show
can be intellectualized and then
it can be experienced and then it can be
realized
right so this is where we're talking
about popping out into these
as roomy and many great mystics have
said
you deepen and deepen and deepen this
enlightened realization
and that once you get to this very
ineffable emptiness
your very source and you pop in and see
that even
the awareness itself
that's all inclusive one god self
was an illusion and a very intoxicative
illusion
and then you pop out
another one back
to reality where you begin in a sense
going like
uh that is object
called camera
like even that phrase
this quote object called a camera
even that phrase becomes so foreign to
you
let alone
the third density matrix
machinery that perpetually keeps people
asleep
so each one of these spiritual concepts
in a sense if you're going to take it
from that very third
density matrix asleep in mint
architectures of our own creation
were such great designers of the
sleeping mint architectures
the very lockless escape rooms the very
chainless chains the very veiless veils
gateless gates that people have to
pierce and walk through
so the idea is that first you get this
intellectual understanding you're like
okay i get it the
cloud is a thought
and it appears and disappears inside of
the awareness that is the sky
and so you know you get this
intellectual understanding and then over
time it becomes more experiential
direct experience and then
it becomes realized and when it's
realized your entire being
shifts your whole perception shifts
what you identify as shifts now you are
way more aware of observation and seeing
in the last couple of months
my ability to abide as awareness
has just gone it's just
increased so significantly and it's been
gorgeous
and so that's the idea is that it
becomes more and more
part of you realized
as you rather than intellectualized or
even direct experience and then beyond
awareness you undergo again the same
process
as you can see below you can think about
it like infinity
where you have this very intellectual
understanding okay infinite awareness
infinite consciousness infinite
witnessing
infinite observation okay infinity
infinity infinity
and then over time it becomes more
experiential where you're like oh my
gosh okay
planet earth is one song
and there's an endless amount of ways
for us to put musical notes into songs
and so we're on the dance the eternal
dance
okay now we're feeling it more and then
you
feel it more and more and more and then
you just get shattered into infinitude
and at that point then the realization
is so effortless
you just vibrate
out the sunlight
but the trick is
is that you haven't emptied out your
conditioning yet
this is really where i'm at right now
i'm at a very cheeky [ __ ] stage
where basically i'm
watching myself hyper vigilantly
and i'm catching my conditioning
repeatedly
and purifying it it's so
cheeky [ __ ] it's unbelievably subtle
most people are so gross and physical
they
have nowhere near they don't even know
where they're coming from ever
they're just chasing the carrots being
dangled by lakshmi
in maya
when you're really analyzing where
you're coming from
this specifically applies to this void
and emptiness
so rather than where you're coming from
coming from your conditioning rather
it's coming from
that shift into permanent alignment with
love light
leela
and so you empty out all of these layers
of conditioning repeatedly over and over
again you
pop out of even the sense of
eye because the sense of eye has so much
[ __ ] baggage and conditioning with it
this little atlas costumes sense of eye
has so much
conditioning that you're not transparent
to
so the atlas costume isn't transparent
to its own conditioning and so the only
way
to honestly purify the conditioning is
to vigilantly watch yourself
and repeatedly purify where you're
coming from so you're not coming from
the garbage-y luggage-y conditioning
and so over time you get to this place
where more and more that
dissolving of the sense of eye to this
place of very
profound emptiness and again things like
this
really help in the process the very
fractally kaleidoscopic
the very also really
you know stuff like this helps a lot as
well
where you gain the very visual
understanding as well of how
the sense of i is completely illusory
your own creation
you created the illusion of the sense of
i so that you could experience these
realities
but the conditioned sense of i does not
want to hear that because the
conditioned sense of eye doesn't want to
die
it doesn't want to dissolve but after it
dissolves you don't just go
into voidness and that's it it's not
what happens
when you it's a layer it's a lens
you're able to navigate from this very
emptiness out to infinitude or to
all-inclusive awareness
or to personal awareness or to
helping somebody navigate with an object
like this microphone if needed
you become a jedi right as we mentioned
you go back to doing the laundry
before enlightenment do laundry after
enlightenment do laundry
but do it abiding as that which created
this entire experience rather than being
a victim
to creation to the world
rather than feeling unsafe which is a
complete illusion
and it's cancerous to society
and so obviously we know mcsure was one
of the best artists that's ever lived
and that spark of the infinite
ended up creating many of the visuals
that help us understand that
we are actually the source that
simulates
reality which further simulates
itself so reality simulates itself into
existence perpetually
the very sense of i simulates
out the experience
of the conditioned sense of i which then
simulates out the next conditioned
experience of the sense of i
until you break that with stream entry
and enter into that
and then create the juxtapositions for
yourself to
decipher between the difference when
you're coming from the [ __ ]
conditioned sense of i versus
when it's just spontaneity
of god's love light aligned arising
in pure service to others really
from the roots purifying repeatedly
and even when you play and you crack
jokes and you dance and you sing and all
of this stuff
it's again it's a very cheeky [ __ ] i'm
experiencing this right now as well
where is it coming from that pure
spontaneity
aligned with god's love light or is
there a little bit of cheeky cutness
to it where there's also a
layer of conditioning that wants to be
seen by
other sparks of the infinite
by itself
so is the bird singing to be seen by
other birds
so you should be able to decipher the
difference between when you're speaking
or playing or creating or whatever for
validation to be seen by other fireworks
by other birds
or when you're just singing because you
[ __ ] love
singing like the bird when you just
firework because you effortlessly do
that
and so here's a little bit more of the
strange loopiness
of the douglas hofstetter
and you can see that very sense of eye
that just goes
as these frames as these very static
frames
every billionth of a second
and that's perpetuating its own illusion
until there is a stream entry into
recognizing the illusion of that very
stickiness
and it can also be visualized this way
as well the very
frames of that movie in these billions
of seconds
and so in this third density
this very
metaphysical map delivered by raw in the
law of one
you're
with this self-awareness this
nature of being able to reflect on your
own nature
and you have this will and choice to
align yourself frame by frame
more and more towards awakening towards
enlightenment
towards deconditioning yourself from
your egoic onion layers to awareness
and then even deconditioning yourself
from that one god
self all-inclusive awareness to the very
source
to void to shunya to emptiness
to that infinitude endlessly expressing
itself and firework
from there purely in service to others
and so as you go through this process
this very strange loopy process
if you see it more and more
kaleidoscopically you will become
more and more
realized in the stage
of
void shunya emptiness and
in the prior stages as well the very
infinitude the very awareness the very
ability to navigate even into the third
density
matrix architectures and be in service
to others
as you do that and so these are all of
the lenses and if you can throw on the
lenses and recognize that you first get
there intellectually
then you get there more and more
experientially and then
it becomes realized and even with the
realize there's no quote
end end although there is an end end
there's also a deepening
so over time you purify more and more
and more and more
you just become a self-purification
engine like bentino says
as well as their
deepening the realization over time as
you
assist more and more in service to
others you refine your abilities as well
all right that's pretty much the core
of the crown assumption of self
so let's
jam on some
more of the musica as we go out
and just remember that
you're
you're very
your very understanding of the crown
assumption being
self the very first attribute being
self the very most sticky
intoxicative part of our creation
being the fact that we create the
ability
to be aware or to know our
experience that
is such a key in the journey that is
such a key in the dance that is such a
key in the process of awakening of
enlightenment
so recognize more and more no self
recognize
more and more anata recognize more and
more
shunya void emptiness purify yourself
away from your conditioning
abide more and more as
coming from a pure mirror place
yeah that's all i hope
the video brought you tremendous value
give it a like
help the algo subscribe if you haven't
leave a comment with your thoughts share
the video with those that you know
this would be profoundly influential on
and
let's jam a bit more on this outro and
then we'll wrap i adore you infinitely
thank you so much
for tuning in
and try the practice right now try to
over time become
more and more sensitive to the
stickiness
and the very illusion of the conditioned
sense of eye
[Music]
okay i'm gonna bring you up to one of my
favorite parts
her transition here is so good
reflect on what is i
what is i what
is i what is
i
[Music]
me
i'll put the link in the bio below
abide
as source as the one
intelligence as the infinite creator
of even god of even the all-inclusive
awareness
become more and more sensitive to the
intoxicative stickiness
of self
transcend even that
conditioned eye to the very
no self empty
um